[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous qui se dit s'intéresse
aujourd'hui aux éoliennes et pour ça
nous sommes en plaine champagne
berrichonne à saint georges sur arnon
une commune qui a fait de l'éolien sa
priorité
dès les années 2000 et on va les voir
les habitants pour savoir ce qu'ils en
pensent plus qu'un gatti des éoliennes
ici ils sont en production depuis
octobre 2009 et combien lena 19 14 sur
la commune de saint georges et cinq sur
la commune de minutes
ça représente quoi en terme de
production c'est à dire l'équivalent de
la ville d'issoudun des besoins de la
ville décideurs que son l'éclairage les
zones industrielles et le chauffage
c'est à dire deux mille habitants
c'est à développer l'emploi ça a
développé la maintenance et la gestion
de parcs éoliens
et puis ça a développé développer des
recettes fiscales pour ou contre les
éoliennes pour pourquoi est-ce que je
pense que c'est l'avenir pour
la planète il centrales nucléaires
moutier ce que ça vaut plus tôt pour eux
en tant qu'agriculteur sur la commune
avec une optique plutôt bio et donc
écologique
je pense que le fait de voir des
éoliennes c'est un peu plus
propre quels sont les inconvénients
alors on dit que c'est moche que ça fait
du bruit qu'ça tuer les oiseaux ou moi
je trouve ça très joli
je trouve ça très élégant dire il
danseuse que je me lève le matin je
regarde la télé sens à son tour n'est
pour moi de me allemand voilà d'accord
elle vous servent de girouette tous les
livres je regarde d'où vient le vent il
me semble peiner à l'heure de l'énergie
renouvelable
il me semble que c'est essentiel et jeu
j'aime votre torrent voir une éolienne
que centrales nucléaires dans le champ
derrière chez moi
[Musique]
quels sont les avantages selon bourg te
rapporte pas mal d'argent la commune ça
permet de faire des projets 144 mille
euros par an pour la commune de saint
georges
je suppose que c'est au niveau fiscal ça
doit être quand même très rentable -
imposition pour les particuliers
entretien du village les espaces verts
je crois qu'ils ont embauché le
personnel vous en avez vu la couleur
vous particulièrement non après bon là
on nous on vient de s'installer en
agriculture en maraîchage donc on a
quand même été aidé par la commune quels
sont les inconvénients
pour moi ça me gêne pas je me suis
habitué le bourg il n'y a pas plus de
bruit que les véhicules sur la nationale
kanté passe
non pour moi ça me convient il ne voit
pas d'inconvénient parce que dans le
berry il y à des riverains dont les
maison jouxte les éoliennes
oui apparemment à 5 600 mètres je crois
on s'est peut-être au niveau du du bruit
peut se disant moi j'entends le
présentant de par chez moi mais c'est
surtout quand il ya du vent pas les one
était quand le vent y portent à revenir
sur le village on entend un espèce de
ouf
asafa bruit des rentrées retourne au
palais le mât mais ce projet non je
pense que tout le pays se développe
niveau des énergies renouvelables pour
qu'on arrive à réduire les énergies
fossiles voir les arrêter
je pense que on est un peu optimiste en
se disant qu'on va arrêter les énergies
fossiles
ben je crois que c'est un peu cuit pour
faire vraiment un avenir tout à fait
beau comme on a pu le vivre pour nos
enfants et petits-enfants et arrière
petits-enfants
non mais c'est vrai nom mais je crois
qu'on a fait trop de bêtises
[Musique]